we've seen this new trend emerge where
athletes all over the world want to be
paid in bitcoin there's saquon barkley
there's trevor lawrence there's stephen
curry there's tom brady there's a bunch
of them they all want to be paid in
bitcoin it's a new trend that has
clearly emerged why do they want to do
this though is the real question there's
a few different reasons in my mind one
is exposure to the asset a guy like
odell beckham jr has made about a
hundred million dollars in his career
he's putting a million dollars into
bitcoin that's one percent exposure i
think that's completely acceptable now
he has exposure to a new asset class
with high upside part of this is also
marketing partnerships so we've seen
deals with cash app with block fi with
ftx and others where they're being paid
millions of dollars in cash to market
these products third is cultural
relevance what we've seen is these guys
want to be known as investors they want
to be seen as forward thinking there is
uh social status that's associated with
this not only online on twitter and
other forums but ultimately they want to
be seen as that forward-thinking
investor that i think is point number
three and what we've continued to see
over time is that there's volatility
right this offers tremendous upside
relative to other investments in their
portfolio so i think every financial
advisor in the world would say one two
three four percent exposure to this
asset is significant and ultimately it
becomes a game of ease of buying too
right if you have the ability to
automatically invest in this asset it
can be set up through apps like strike
and others where it automatically
downloads and it automatically purchases
it kind of like a savings account that
you would use for something else that is
another way why they have this and then
who have we seen doing this right we
have saquon barkley odo beckham jr aaron
rodgers trevor lawrence kade cunningham
but it's not just athletes we've now
seen politicians getting into the game
miami mayor francis suarez and new york
city mayor eric adams they're literally
competing on twitter who can take more
of their paycheck and bitcoin and i
think what we're going to see over the
next one two three four five years is
this trend is only going to get stronger
people want to status signal what
they're interested in why they believe
in bitcoin and other digital assets john
why do you think this is happening i
think you hit it right on the head there
with all the advantages right athletes
want to be it's newsworthy so athletes
can get in the news simply by taking a
portion of their salary or all of their
salary in bitcoin we saw russell [ __ ]
originally but then has moved to other
athletes as well and then also in the
fight for politicians taking their
salary bitcoin it's really hard for them
because the the u.s kind of constricts
them on what they can get paid in and
what asset they can get paid in but if
they have the ability to automatically
convert their money with an ease of mind
mindset saying hey take 10 of what i
earn and go ahead and immediately
invested in this asset you're basically
being paid in bitcoin at that point and
i think we're going to see more
politicians do this in the future more
athletes do in the future but over time
i think that the
um the power that each newsworthy thing
has goes down over time so first guy to
do with russell [ __ ] blew up now we see
more and more people doing it but it
doesn't have the same punch that it used
to have yeah and i think it depends
right a lot of it is the same reasons
that drive an individual like you or me
to do it right we like the asset we want
exposure to it we want the ease of use
and it's savings technology that we
believe in and wants to continue to
invest our capital into same thing
applies for professional athletes i
think they believe in a lot of the same
stuff but in the day like marketing
money's marketing money also if you can
get paid money to do it and promote a
product why not if you're going to do it
with your own money anyways why would
you not make news with it and go do it
with the salary that you're earning from
a team anyways i think we're going to
continue to see it over the next few
years and it's going to be fascinating
to watch how many professional athletes
all around the world continue to do this